my girl got I forget what kind of last
not Brazilian some others wax I was a
god I feel like that be nice to do my
booty hole in balls did you ever do that
they call it they called the BB balls
him I will say that I keep it I keep it
well clipped under their would you do
the last I don't like dingleberries you
do the less I don't think I would do the
wax I don't like what I said ask him how
to do it for guys and you got to get on
all fours and then spread your feet yeah
you would like that you would enjoy it
you would enjoy it and I believe in my
heart and soul 100% that you're not only
going to do it but probably already have
so I thank you breaking the ice breaking
your lights on this podcast first of all
I am appalled but I am I expected from
you by karadayi your [ __ ] rump hole
is about as smooth and I feeling just a
bad idea I feel like this here down
there for a reason I feel like that
would be a bad idea I think you should
only you know how they have to get like
the tape from the balls of those you
know yeah well Brennan printed that is
so disturbing to me okay your presume to
get your damn ankles near I'll put you
put your ankles on my shoulder I'm on
professional dudes that's someone's job
I know
put your IT dollars you gotta go once a
month it's used a large Russian woman
who never smiles not my grocer is a
pretty black on what that's problems
that's wrong I would need to do like ah
I'd rather have the big warlock to
handle it then some pretty girl or done
is that okay a guy I mean in other words
just a dude who's like who's like I got
a hole here done put the UM put the lip
of the wax the guy's like this guy's
like hey I got to do it right that's how
it goes brother no my wife the other one
Eastwood doing it no you're gonna walk
in my own high ya later guys like
everybody I do it yeah I got to do is I
do this [ __ ] - I'll [ __ ] do it and
you want to look like after this yeah
well you wanna do a molest your ass and
when you comes out of his mouth I'm
gonna paint this whack this this wax on
just going to hurt a little bit but no
but one piece of level 200 bite by the
Daleks and you don't realize the damage
that you're doing in your brain and I
think I told you before what I was doing
on my podcast I was talking about how
many times are being punched in the head
they had 106 fights in me career so I
don't know Matt's amateur and pro even
how much like Alma to improve I've done
the math so for each one of these fights
if I if I spot ten times each spawn
session was six rounds and each one of
them spawn sessions that were hidden
they had seven times anyway I don't know
14 months the work I've been punched in
the head give or take around 55,000
times for a lot of times it's a lot of
times and I remember I do not know what
looks like [ __ ] that's when I start
thinking maybe I'm a little bit punchy I
walk out I walk out and there was a guy
there my name is Niall user former world
champions in the gym and I said to him I
when mean I've just done the maths of
getting punched in the head over 55,000
times
he was like [ __ ] he said I had 250
fights imaginary terms are being punched
in the head they've been in wars yeah
and I went wow I went do you think it's
affected gaben nah it's merely smaller I
was like 40 now
I'll say made smart can really give me
that means your CD yeah
do you think that made you smarter
that's the dad damn prodded and and now
if it has affected me I'm very happy
that I'm in the position now the realize
that has affected us and I went for them
Korean testing in Vegas oh you did do
the other plane troubles desk yeah it
was only Allison
time again the Olympic champion telling
me go and do these tests in it's called
a Cleveland Clinic in Vegas it's the
best facility in the world you have to
pay for it no it was all free to flew
media team I wouldn't mind doing it you
should the live in my house we come here
and do it did you ever think about our
stuff while you were fighting though I
don't I don't think you can afford to
Canyon otherwise you fight - yeah yeah
why why do some stupid [ __ ] sparring
like mean Shane Carwin when the hardest
punchers of all time to ever grace the
octave we didn't we'll just stand
flat-footed and just punch each other
because we were Wonder I don't knows be
meathead right yeah I mean you don't
realize now I'm on the opposite no I was
I was loosening the speed ball in the
gym and you know the speed bag the foot
and fell on me head and [ __ ] and it hurt
like [ __ ] and things like that
touch me again and like you said when
you fight and you don't really realize
that you do not wish she and Colin just
go like it looks like what
like thinking I remember of me unfound
letting someone punch in the fist like
come on then whatsoever I know you know
fathers it's like the bravado I fit in
it right whenever ad spies like sea
stars or something to get a bit buzzed
I'm nice that's what you saw yeah all
right yeah so [ __ ] weird so yeah no
I'm no I realized that damages that
boxing can do to do here and you know I
know I know that's why I'm so happy to
be able to know what what these these
signals that's that's that's well I want
you to I want you to do me a favor
before we do anything I want you guys in
your in your sexiest voice I want me to
say once you lose that shirt and get you
moving around the corner over there hey
Brian yeah got a couple ideas for you
real quick yeah I know it's Wednesday I
know it's midweek yeah we're in a
basement what's going on yeah great
basement yeah I know you're like you
like these fancy basement side B's
basements with just a couple mics and in
a couple chairs never said that here's
the idea I wanted to get to okay once
you lose that shirt fine go play with
yourself in the corner what was the
second part of it
look around move around around a little
rattled around the corner I like play
with a quarter bed that's so good I'd
take a little bit already I just go
ahead and move around the corner I mean
also is ridiculous as me same play with
yourself in the club like just move
around around then you can add something
more outside creepy zone I don't hear me
move around and then you can say some
but I guess it's like dealer's choice
like whatever move around means not your
plaid will do it and then when I'm
racing when I move around I want you to
go I want you to really quietly say that
I'll make a noise with your mom okay
I'll do it
hey Brian yeah happy Wednesday first of
all oh happy one yeah people don't say
that midweek Sunday Funday terrific
Tuesday
Freaky Friday okay I'm about the midweek
compliments okay every Wednesday happen
yeah I know you love shirts but I'm
looking to get rid of that shirt why
don't you take that shirt off bra but go
to that corner huh move around for a
little bit move around yeah you know how
to move around yeah I guess I've been
doing it for years
now I'm staging off like this slower not
faster oh I do a slow fast combo um keep
your torso type move your head like a
peacock
yes i applying the peacock gown it's a
nickname for comfortable no you're very
calm you look comfortable
okay I make a noise with your mouth what
you heard me
it's safe with the same concern that you
said what oh there it is quickly oh yeah
it is found that your toes more socks up
[ __ ] such analysis